president biden trying to reassure
everyone that he is running again in
2024 but he may have made things worse
do you plan to run for re-election yes
but look
i'm a great respecter of fate
fate has intervened in my life many many
times
if i'm in the health i'm in now
if i'm in good health
then in fact i would run again and if
that means a rematch against donald
trump
you're trying to tempt me now
sure
why would i not run against donald trump
or the nominee that increased the
prospect of running
biden's comments coming just days after
his own vp kamala harris said the two
haven't even talked about running for a
second term and speaking of kamala she's
back to complaining about the press
according to a new report harris has
been privately griping that the media
coverage would be much better if she was
a white man so kaylee first to you what
about a trump biden matchup 2.0
oh that would be
very interesting indeed it's really
funny to watch joe biden grin like a
chess shire cat at that prospect
lucky for joe or unlucky for joe he
won't be able to remain in the basement
i mean america has woken up to what it's
like when you elect a president who hid
from the american people didn't share
with us a secret covered plan so match
up 2.0 would be excellent what's
interesting katie this is the first time
he's kind of caveated his answer of will
he run again this time he had that
nuance of his health and what's
fascinating his members of his own
administration refused to shut down talk
of him not running you know pete buddha
judge when he was on air force two with
kamala harris he was asked are you going
to run in 2024 and rather than saying no
my boss is joe biden i work for joe
biden i fully expect president joe biden
to run and be re-elected as president
joe biden he didn't do that he said oh
it's 20 21. the same thing kamala
essentially said oh we haven't talked
about 2024 it's interesting cause i can
tell you this if alex azar or other
members of the trump administration
cabinet had entertained running or not
shut down that kind of talk they'd be
called to the oval office real quick
yeah absolutely so jesse shouldn't joe
biden run for a second term just to try
and salvage his reputation that
considering his approval ratings are
lower than jimmy carter he's like you
just have to get above jimmy carter and
then you can bow out i think he's one
and done katie
he told the truth he said honestly if
i'm feeling okay i'll run if i'm not in
good health i won't run but when you're
an honest politician you opened up a lot
of problems and he opened up huge
problems with this answer how's the
world looking at this joe just lame
ducked himself in front of our allies in
front of our enemies they could just
wait him out if he's only going to be
around for maybe three more years what
about the country the country's thinking
to themselves wait a second if if his
health is an issue tomorrow well
is it an issue today because we got a
pandemic we got a rocky recovery here
and the democrats
they better start making contingency
plans i'm sure
mayor pete's donor's eyes lit up when
they saw that david murray interview or
commerce probably
launched an exploratory committee this
afternoon but they need to start
planning ahead for something like this
the squad might be looking at this guy
like he's politically wounded like they
can roll him
but he introduced this
on a network television interview this
is now front and center his health in
mainstream conversation this isn't you
know a conservative commentator saying
you know the guy's lost his fastball
this isn't a democrat whispering in the
halls of congress you know he's he's not
the same as he used to be
he introduced this on network tv now
everyone is going to see everything he
does in the context of his failing
health every cough
every stumble every time he has a light
schedule you're going to look at this
and siegel said last night on tucker he
said this guy had a nice bill of health
when the doc just looked at him but he
had this really
new gait that wasn't really right and
they ran a bunch of neurological tests
on him we haven't seen the results of
those maybe joe's seen the results of
those maybe he's reacting to those
results we don't know
but this is this is a whole new ball
game now
yeah you know richard you know a week
ago the deputy press secretary insisted
that joe biden was running again he has
now said that there is a possibility
that he won't run the vice president has
said that she hasn't talked to the
president about running again which is
an indication in itself so who would be
the one to take his place
well i think the president's running uh
but with that being said just like the
president i too am a man of faith and
while i plan on celebrating quizzes with
my family it's very possible that i
could get sick tomorrow it's very
possible anybody on this panel could get
sick tomorrow
and so i think what the president was
trying to say very clearly is my plan is
to run but we have to understand that we
live in the real world three years ago
when when when when kalia and the white
house and the trump white house was
planning for trump's re-election they
didn't expect covet 19. we live in a
world that's dynamically changing and i
think the president was acknowledging
that change very clearly in that in that
exchange there no but just to interrupt
richard every politician says yeah i
feel great and i'm running just shuts
down the conversation shuts everything
down
that joe biden's an honest man so he's
just being honest with you i think the
married people should appreciate it i
think he was too i think he was honest
to a fault with this one
yeah let's get sean i have questions
about you know jesse mentioned that joe
biden lame ducked himself in that
interview that's true but his agenda was
also killed this week with buildback
better
is he a lame duck or is he going to be
able to kind of revive his build back
better plan in the spring
no listen i think they're going to keep
pushing you know aspects of bill back
better but just the way the
congressional calendar works and midterm
elections work they only have until you
know
late february late march to actually get
these things done before everyone calls
it quits and goes home and and campaigns
again but i think when you talk about
joe biden again it calls into question
what does good health actually mean
because i think i mean many people would
say he he doesn't look like he's in good
health right now um and he brings it up
because he's getting really old but i
mean three years is a long time before
the 2024 election but i don't think he's
gonna get different results i mean when
you look at the border
uh crime inflation no oil and gas the
problem is these are all self-inflicted
wounds by joe biden and if he doesn't
change course we're going to be living
with this for three years and when you
see hispanics and independents bail from
the democrat party it's going to get
worse uh than it is right now three
years from now he's trying to run for
reelection democrats are going to beg
him to retire to get someone else in to
get a fresh slate hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else